what's your name  this is how andrew schultz does crowd  work what's your name  and you  yo he starts the crowd work with a  conversational question what is your  name black people step it up yo step it  up first of all you need to give that so  damn black shirt to that woman right  there okay  and it's called crowd work for a reason  use the entire crowd he asks her name  but then brings in the crowd by saying  hey she should be wearing your shirt now  the crowd is working  get it crowdwork  janana that's a white woman named janana  black people that are a little bit older  have you ever heard of a white person  named janana  all right follow for more tips